you're right there's a lot of ish like
but I know a lot of people that don't
want kids because of the way our world
has been going yeah so I think that may
have up but why why is it like that the
world's going like we have a lower rate
of poverty than we ever have had in the
entire human history really yeah as much
as we should coming from L.A everybody
know that how are we in general we're
not getting paid as much as we should no
because the way inflation has gone up
through oh inflation's bad yeah we're
not getting paid more so it's like like
right you're right you're our wages my
parents my parents are able to buy a
house right right out of college
that is impossible like in our day and
age it's impossible it's just not gonna
happen we could barely pay rent like
with just a regular job like with no
experience of coming out of college like
you know it's just not there's a a lot
of things in the way that weren't in the
way tend so you're saying you're saying
like a lot of people well but the other
problem is like Consumer Debt and like
that's like 80 percent Consumer Debt is
owned by women so like women aren't like
good at saving so it's like partially
like our own fault if we're in a problem
where you have 80 like 80 like because
the other genders aren't doing it I
think men are more confident like when
it comes to money management depends on
family as well
I just recently started having our own
bank accounts isn't it that a woman
could
until like shortly after uh voting was
yeah but yeah but what does that have to
do with us today like nothing no no no
no I'm sorry no no this is that had
nothing to do with me something that
happened in the 20s I felt like like 20s
that was only 30. even let's say 50s 60s
I wasn't alive you can't you can't
believe you're spending you can know you
cannot blame yourself
I've let you talk a lot Jessica
listen at the end of the day being a
woman of color when it comes to money
and all that we're a lot more careful
about this kind of stuff because it was
19. you know our history does not prove
well when it comes to finances and
education you know and we're trying to
work better well it's something that
should be taught in school yeah
financial literacy investing exactly in
my high school yeah we needed at least
two years of financial literacy classes
so but you know when you have half of
the country not even even being able to
read at a sixth grade level it
it's gonna get kind of hard for us to
have a understanding of both reading and
money like I think that one reason why
that statistic that you shared is so low
amongst women
is
um
you like spark something is because that
we
it's shared more like financial literacy
and correct me if I'm wrong it shared
more with
people who are wealthy wealthy yeah
already wealthy and that typically comes
from the Caucasian community and it's
something that isn't well I'm talking
about like women owning consumers yeah
that's what I'm saying like Okay it's
taught to bring up that intersection but
I'm saying like even if it's like the
wealthy people have that knowledge like
they
[Music]
um like it's half women like yeah but
I'm saying just like the dynamic of
whatever Community you come from I don't
know yeah I'm gonna come from this
community that Community but it's
very
um
yeah it's not talked about it as much
and I can understand why that would be
low because of just the Dynamics from do
you feel like the the internet though is
kind of the great equalizer because you
have access to all this information that
like like you can you can look up like a
billionaire giving someone Financial
advice yeah I do think that you can
access anything and everything on the
internet but if it's not something that
you grew up with you've been taught like
this is important like financial
literacy you need to understand it
you're not going to look it up on your
own I just from what I've seen I don't
think it's like a community thing like I
think women just spend money on like
clothes and like like like more like
looks yeah like like I think women just
have worse spending habits than yeah and
I do think that and I think think has
been
how often do you see
[ __ ] about the men's section yeah
our whole media is like marketed towards
women everything you see is like for a
female audiences us into a corner except
for this show yeah
it becomes an issue in society at that
point can I say something yeah yeah go
ahead I
to give that to an extent
[Music]
um I think I disagree with that to an
extent I can't like personally I'm that
woman there I care about how I look but
that's because my passion for fashion
right um
but I think in terms there's a lot of
guys males that are very invested in how
they look a lot more at the moment
whereas moment it's wrong statistically
you're wrong
no it's the same way
you're you're thinking of exceptions
yeah exceptions
yeah men will make a big purchase
as well
person is
actually she's not in the fashion
business
plays one in fashion for father
Yes it does it's very nice they have
great graphics I actually play around in
fashion for fun that's not their career
but they get a kick out of it yeah
because they like it yeah I know but
like like again remember when we're
having these conversations we're talking
about in general we're not talking about
like you wanna because why does your
your mind go to a specific it's like you
want to argue because you're like oh
this one person is an exception to them
because but a stereotype but stereotypes
are backed up by yeah like if they're
back to buy data ads in like Gap in the
window like 90 minutes
straight up because the target audiences
us fashion is fully rooted in women yeah
like
accessories right exactly like
because they know we're gonna spend that
was the only thing that we could do at
some point like also and also I think
that this Society I think that the main
thing is like
women
I don't know the statistics of how many
women are in the world how many men but
typically sex cell and women are
sexualized and so that's why they gear
to us like they know they're gonna buy
the stuff they know if they have if they
see a woman wearing something there that
they're looking in this the women are
gonna be like but are they sexualized
for men or for women if women make 80
percent of consumer purchasing decisions
I think it's both I think right I agree
I agree they really look like
historically like let's look like
historically like when like when women
wore corsets and they wore this little
right things
and layers right that was because they
were being brought out into society to
find a husband and they were being
sexualized so I feel like that's also a
point to be made like they like when
they had money it's like oh well let's
spend this on a dress but again Gabby
but what is that a like what does that
have to do with us today
I just believe in personal
responsibility like if you have bad
credit and you're born in 2020 like
that's your own fault